actually is whether some Philadelphia hi
actually how are you how are you better
than I deserve what's up I'm a new
listener and recently came across her
page on YouTube and after listening to a
couple videos I've seen to have had and
financial epiphany and realized that I
am lost
okay I thought I was I have 64 thousand
and student loan debt from undergrad and
graduate school I don't have a true
working budget I'm don't have three to
six months worth of savings and I'm
confused as to where I should start
I don't have credit card debt I do have
at least a thousand emergency savings
but in terms of next steps it's you know
do I focus on just that loan that
savings you know for there 1k or you're
a looks I'm quite sure you're catching
on pretty quick it sounds like you've
got this analyzed very quickly what's
your degree in oh oh I think I just lost
you oh well see if you can get her back
miss Kelly actually again we got cut off
earlier oh good I'm glad you got back
through okay okay you are you lose if I
can remember you you were getting you
had your thousand dollars you were brand
new at all of this and you were sucking
at budgeting and you're trying to get
started does that sound right yes oh
okay my two biggest pieces were 64k and
student loan and then I currently have a
lease a car lease that will be up in six
months in six months what's the monthly
on that 408 Oh
nice car alright so what do you make a
year gross I make 80 mm-hmm it doesn't
feel like it no because weird part I
think that's fact where the realization
came from yeah
disorganized and you got oh is that
sucking the life out of you and you got
a freaking $400 car payment that's the
other thing how much is your rent it's
1,200 okay all right cool okay here's
the thing the first thing that's going
to help a whole bunch is jump on every
dollar and put together your budget it
takes about ten minutes when you put at
the top of the page what your take-home
pay is and you give every dollar of that
an assignment a name a mission you're
gonna feel like you got a raise right
then just because you got organized
knowing that you got the light bill paid
knowing that you have the money for food
there's a tremendous relief emotionally
to begin to attack some of these other
things that's the first thing you're
going to have occur so go to every
dollar and download it for your phone or
for your for your desktop either one I
don't care which okay are you do you
have money coming out of your check for
401 K yes that's what I was going to
mention I'm I do have I do have
withdrawals for 401 k IRA but I'm not
maxing out good stop it stop it right
now yeah because we're gonna get this
mess cleaned up okay probably as little
time as you have left on the lease
you're probably better off to just hold
that lease through the end
but we've got to get a little money
saved up to bike a little guy little get
around car because you're gonna turn
that puppy in right yeah you only got
six months left so that's only two
thousand dollars left on that thing and
you can work your way right back through
that and you're gonna be able to do this
I'm gonna walk with you I'll show you
how hold on I'm gonna send you a copy
the book the Total Money Makeover it
walks you through exactly what to do
step by step and you can do it but stop
your 401k temporarily we're gonna put
that thousand dollars aside we'll get
you on a budget we're gonna begin to
attack these debts we're gonna plan to
turn that car in you got this you can do
it